(dissonance)
(light piano music)
(static)
- What's an eight-letter
word for hairless?
Oh, it is hairless.
- Was the clue hairless?
- Nevermind, forget it.
Is that our toolbox?
Where are our tools?
- I just thought it was a
waste of a good box, so.
- Well what are you making?
- Well you know how we're
going to Dave's thing later?
- Oh, yeah, is that tonight?
- Yeah, so I just
thought I'd make a dip
that we could bring.
- A dip?
Is Dave's thing
the sort of thing
that you bring something to?
- Um, I don't know,
I don't remember exactly
what the deal was.
Do we have any cumin?
- No, we're out, but the
place down the street
probably has some.
- Okay.
Cumin?
Am I saying that right?
- Cu-min.
What'd you say the first time?
- I said cu-min.
- Cu-min.
- Cumin.
(alarms sounding)
Yeah, I can't remember
what Dave said.
- Yeah, I just don't want
to be the only people
that don't bring something,
you know what I mean?
I just feel like
that's the worst.
- Well, if we bring a dip,
do we have to bring
something to dip into it?
- No no, someone else will
bring something that we can dip.
- I don't think you
can just assume that.
- Yeah you can, because
there's so many things
that can be dipped, I mean,
carrots, I don't
know, so many things.
- We should bring something
you can dip, just to be safe.
- Yeah, but like,
what, you know?
- I don't know, you're
the one who said
that there are so many
things you can dip.
- Yeah.
- I just think that...
- Did we walk the wrong way?
- No, I guess it's just gone.
Well, depending on
what you're going for,
you could try dill.
- Do we have dill?
- Oh yeah, so much.
- Okay, well dill might even
be kinda better in a way,
you know what I mean?
(dissonant music)
- Hey.
- Hi guys.
- Hi.
This is my new boyfriend, Myron.
- Hey, I'm Charlie.
- I love your lantern.
- Oh, thanks.
- Hi, I'm Matt.
Did you guys bring
anything that we could dip?
- What?
- Alright, so I recoupled the
electric engine's drive shaft
to the old yoke's chassis.
Wasn't the prettiest workaround,
but it'll get the job done.
Hey guys.
- Hey.
- Hi Dave.
- Hi Matt.
Thanks for coming guys.
I know it's a huge risk
we're all taking here.
I don't know what's out there.
All right?
All I know is, there's nothing
left here for us anymore.
It's just us now.
It's us against the world.
- Oh, nice, you brought tools.
- Oh, uh, actually it's a dip.
- What?
- Gross.
Why would you bring a dip?
- It's not gross.
- We kinda just assumed that
someone would bring something
to dip into it.
- Why would someone bring
snacks to this, guys?
- Why don't you just
tell the truth and admit
that you forgot what
we were doing here.
- I brought carrots, if
anybody's interested.
- Oh.
- Thank you.
- I'm sorry, who's this?
- This is Myron,
my new boyfriend.
- What happened to Tyler?
(sighs)
- Jesus Christ, man.
- Even I knew about that.
- Alright listen guys,
if we're gonna move,
let's move now, because--
- I don't wanna be rude, but
there aren't enough seatbelts
for Myron.
- What are you talking about?
Just squeeze in.
- With an extra person--
- Oh, uh, shotgun.
- No, you're not
shotgun, no, I'm shotgun.
- You have to call it.
- I don't call it.
I don't call anything.
I am shotgun.
- Yeah, she doesn't
have to call it.
- I get car sickness
pretty easily.
If I could sit in the front
seat, I'd really appreciate it.
- Myron, no one invited you.
- And he didn't
even bring anything.
- I brought the carrots.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, he brought
carrots, number one.
Number two, he's with me.
And three, he's as
entitled to be here
as any one of you guys,
way more entitled to be
here than you two schnooks.
- Come on, Hannah.
- Schnooks?
- What?
What skill do you have?
What are you bringing
to the table?
- Uh...
- Umm...
- What skill are you
bringing, Hannah?
- I made a sling out of a
skirt that wasn't even mine.
- Okay, well I can
run really fast.
- Between the two of
us he's the fastest.
I wouldn't say that you're
fast compared to everyone.
- We have to compare--
- I stood in the four corners.
- I'm very inspiring.
Nobody wants to give up
when they're around me.
- I can name all
of the presidents
in reverse chronological order.
- I'm a neurologist.
- I have thin wrists.
You'd be surprised
how useful that is.
- Well I can balance
on a rolling log.
- I can taste cilantro.
- That doesn't count
as a skill, though.
(everyone talking
over each other)
- I'm a very, very,
very positive person.
- I made gunpowder
from a branch.
- That's not gonna come
in handy at some point.
(car engine starts)
(crickets)
- Can you please put the
tools back in the box
when we get home?
- Yeah.
Yes.
The dill works, right?
- Yeah, it's good.
- Wait, what are we doing?
- Oh yeah.
- When was the last
time you even saw a bus?
- I don't know.
(dissonant music)